Don't drop it, man. They're fragile.
Umm...
Yo, batter up.
That is gonna break it.
Don't. Just ta-
Yo, Clint. You need a battery? All right, here you go.
Oh, thanks, dude.
Does this- Does this actually work?
- Yeah. Actually, let me see that real fast?
Oh, thanks.
Yeah, I think it's good.
Yeah? -Yeah.
Whoops. My bad.
- Hey, Clint. Can I see the battery?
Yeah, here you go.
Oh, sorry. Here
- Yo, Clint!
(bleeps) damn it!
Careful. You might break it. - Yeah
Oh, Niko!
It has a hundred and one percent.
Hey, Clint. Can I see the battery? I gotta put it on the camera.
- Yeah, for sure.
Okay, we put on the camera now-- whoops! It slipped!
Niko!
Niko - Sorry!
Be gentle.
Here you go, man.
Ok. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on
Give me a real battery (x2)
That's a real battery. -A REAL battery.
You put it on.
Clint's like: I ain't touching that!
Kinda put it straight in here.
- So do you feel comfortable if I invite the dancers in and started getting them placed?
Yes.  -Great
It works fine. (Laughs)
It needs a- It needs- It needs a
It's a rough draft and we need to revise it.
It's 4:25 and we are currently writing the script for the video we're shooting tomorrow.
Today we are shooting a video called "Early Access Matrix."
Why would we figure out the script last second and shoot it the next morning?
That might seem a little rushed and it-
and it is. But, why?
I think we're trying to be consistent. Finally.
Clint and Adrian are working with us in the studio
We have a lot of filmmakers who are trying to do shorts for the Corridor channel-
and we're like, okay, you know what?
Let's- let's up our output. Let's get more consistent. Let's try and find a more regular schedule
The main point, though, is that we got to be shooting videos more often.
I decided to kick it off by getting this 'Early Access Matrix' video, shot and filmed
After eight years of filmmaking and doing shorts like this
it's a little easier for me to roll into something without a plan and then still get a video that turns out.
Brandon once describes the way their schedule works--
So when we're doing the Freddiew videos,
the way we keep on schedule is
we picked a date and time that we're going to come out
So we're weekly- Thursday's at like 9 a.m. For a long time.
We picked that day because we felt like it was open the way the front page at the time worked was like-
we had slots
that we wanted to hit to maximize our exposure.
We're like, "That's when the next video is gonna be,"
So when it came time to start making it, it's Sunday. We have four days to go through to get that video done,
so we have, you know, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday and then up to Thursday.
But we couldn't come up with anything on Sunday,
on Monday the exercise became like this- the pressure mounted, right?
It's like now it we have to come up with an idea that we need in three days.
that's gonna "wow" the audience and people are going to enjoy it.
Then on Tuesdays, we got two days. Uh, Wednesday, one day. And sometimes we get so far it'll be--
it'll be Wednesday evening and we still wouldn't have an idea
but by that point with 12 hours. Like- the pressures really starting to mount
And interestingly some of the best videos we ever made came out of that system.
Like, for example.... 'Cereal Killer'
The lessons that we learned doing that was:
"Try very hard to come up with something earlier and stay ahead of it
And so put the pressure on that because we know how bad it was snowballed."
But by never letting ourselves slip, it kind of treated through that
discipline and helped us the exercise of ideation
Think of coming up with ideas, like a- like a muscle
just like anything else
It's like "you want a muscle get stronger?"
You go to the gym, you work out,
you plan activities to make- strengthen that muscle
If you want to come up with ideas more efficiently,
you're never going to come up with them unless you're setting a set time
it's like, "We gotta,
we gotta do it and we got to do it under pressure,"
and it's- it's interesting is often- like, during those brainstorm sessions,
we're like, "I need an idea. I need an idea. I need an idea."
The idea would never- would rarely come during that.
But, then once you're like,
Ugh, let's take a break and go to lunch. *snaps*
At lunch, that's when you come up the idea.
Or hop in the shower? That's when you come up with the idea.
It would never just happen in a shower
if you weren't already putting in the hours to, like, try to come up those ideas outside.
It's just interesting but ideas would rarely come during the, like, actual brainstorming;
instead, they come out around it.
Don't fall for us. Our videos are still gonna be pretty big
We're shooting videos for every single week for at least the next two months.
Everyone knew this video wasn't totally ready,
but I was still like, "Hey, I'm still shooting. We're still shooting."
We're figuring it out right now. Yes, we're shooting tomorrow morning.
I would much rather just shoot and get a video. Light that fuse. You know what I mean?
We have a huge eight week schedule--
*lighting fuse* We're- let's set it on fire. Let's go.
All right. We are on our way to the Cine Gear Expo
Where we are going to be meeting with Anton Bauer battery company.
Anton Bauer is like one of the old standbys of
battery tech in the film industry.
Back in the day, they made a solid battery that had a mount called the Gold Mount.
It's been used for basically every professional camera. Anytime, you see, like, a camera as the prop in the movie,
It's usually an Anton Bauer battery on the back of it.
They have new batteries that just launched today. No, yesterday.
They're brand new- a whole bunch of new tech in them and they make V-locks.
We use V-lock batteries for all of our cameras, in our Reds,
and use gold mount for all the lights.
Why do I do that?
-Yeah.
I like to keep our batteries a little bit separate
so that we have a set of batteries just dedicated to our lights
then a set of batteries just dedicated to our cameras.
I hate wires,
so that's why I use batteries for all our lights
and that's why they're all LED.
Most people don't know that Anton Bauer makes v-lock batteries.
So now, you know.
Anton Bauer makes V-lock batteries.
Anyways, let's go!
We are in New York City.
I just drove down to New York City, guys.
And there's a camera car
So here it is, the new battery.
Cool, just launched yesterday?
- Launched yesterday- publicly launched yesterday. They're in stock in all dealers around North America
and Europe already.
So you could walk into, you know, B&H for example today, and go and get one
-Cool
You could get one in V-mount if you wanted to.
We make V-mounts now. Yeah, in fact, we've been doing it since 2014. We just didn't tell anyone.
So new battery.
You know, it's more compact than our last generation battery,
but at the same time more long-lived and more powerful.
It says ninety on the front, but it's actually ninety-nine watt hours. So 10% more for your money.
We keep it under a hundred
so it's flight safe right for you after,
so you can put as many of these in your carry-on as you wish and take it on an aircraft which is convenient.
The battery tells you percentage when it's just sitting there
and when you put it on a camera
it gives you a runtime clock
in hours or minutes.
It has to be touch switched like if you have it on an iPhone or anything.
If you triple tap it, it goes into diagnostic mode.
USB and P-tap on there...
Yeah,
We put USB on there and we're finding the people are using it for charging their cell phone.
- So, I can just have a really fancy cell phone charger right here?
Yep.
So this is yours, Niko. Take it, have a play.
-Cool. Thank you.
Don't drop it, man. They're fragile.
Delete that clip.
Wow, that's-
-Dude, that's- (bleep)
Sorry...
They're- they're built to take this. Just- just be careful with it.
- We'll go home and we'll plug this into a Red and
we'll see if it still works.
Sweet!
- Dude!
All right, so what's a reflector? What is a reflector?
Anything that's reflective. It's a silk.
Well, it's a fine, fine thing made from a- presumably made from like spiders or something.
We go back and forth between using reflectors and silks
and I kinda wanted to talk about it because we have our own kind of technique that we've developed.
So, our silks and our reflectors are about the same size.
We travel with them. They're supposed to be lightweight,
supposed to be a small crew.
The technique we use to decide whether we're gonna use a reflector or a diffuse
kind of comes through necessity because we only have reflectors and diffusers of certain sizes.
They're not huge.
So when you have sunlight and you're using a reflector
That means you have two sources of light;
and very frequently, if you're using a reflector outside
you can actually just flatten out your lighting.
Let's say you're backlit by the Sun and then you bounce it back into someone's face,
Well, suddenly you have light everywhere. There's no more shading. There's no more lighting for that matter.
Sometimes you kind of need to do that, though.
We can't use the diffuse in the wide so we're gonna use a reflector in the wide
We're gonna even it out by
shooting the light at an opposite or an oblique angle
to create a little bit of shading or a little bit of fill and then when we go in close
We can now use our diffusers to even out the light and get a nice soft closeup on someone's face.
I personally like that style
It makes it so when you're in a close-up
you're paying a little more attention to the person's natural features
rather than the weird lighting
and inconsistent contrast and shading that a
poorly placed Sun is giving you--
and when you're in a wide
It basically makes it so that way, when you are trying to look at someone's reaction in a wide shot
there is light hitting it
and you're able to read it still.
Brings a little clarity to the wides
and it brings a little beauty the close-ups.
There's no real right or wrong way to use diffuse or reflectors.
You know, when you're filming in Minnesota for example.
Winter filmmaking in Minnesota,
your lighting is great all the time
because the Sun is always just a little bit lower on the horizon.
It's never straight up since you're a little farther north of the Equator
The sun's always at a lower angle in winter. In those situations,
I'm definitely using a reflector
because you have that Sun always kind of at one of these lower angles
You can start playing with your light
When it's top down though, you gotta diffuse it.
You got to diffuse it or else people just- their faces get all messed up.
Inside the battery, there's an accelerometer.
And every time it experiences a shock of more than 100 G--
and 100 G sounds pretty bad--
But actually that's only a drop from about two feet onto a hard floor.
Every time it experiences a drop like that,
it records it and it actually creates time and date stamp as well
So you can- you can see when your battery was dropped.
Put that that on a charger or something
you can pull that information off
If the battery is still functional,
keep using it.
They're gonna experience knocks and bangs during their life
And one thing you don't want to worry about is your battery failing
so we build it so it doesn't.
Hey, Carmichael. You wanna see a trick?
- Yeah, man.
There you have it.
Does it still work?
-Uh, I assume.
Alright, we're gonna test out and see if it still works after all that.
And... moment of truth...
Boom! - Hey!
Still works!
You're gonna run for five hours.
Here's the new battery.
- Dude, I love batteries.
So this is- is this like the- the super strong kind of hard-to-break battery?
- Yes
Man, you guys have already scuffed it up.
Hold on,
There's a USB port in this battery.
- I know isn't that nice?
You in charge your phone off of this like 25 times.
- Geez
Okay, so 14 volts 69 hundred million th-
Wha- that just feels so wrong!
Why would you do that to me right now?
Yo, batter up.
- Dude, that- that is gonna break it.
That is gonna break it.
- Don't break it.
Don't- don't. Just tap it.
Well, let's see if it boots.
It works.
I mean the camera is not fully booted up yet. It can't be possibly reading it correct.
There's no way. Can't possibly be getting the current reading!
That's really cool.
- Wait, you were just pressing something. Is it a touch-
Yeah - There's a touch pad?
Wait, what? What?
And you're still just throwing it around-
- You wanna play with it?
I can't get my head around that. That's just so wrong!